c'est le nouveau café branché de Tokyo
des robots humanoides accueil servent
les clients ils sont équipées de caméras
et de micro pour recevoir les commandes
ses robots sont en fait l'avatar
d'employés qu'il est contrôle à distance
des personnes à mobilité réduite travail
de la maison le robot présente l'employé
au client
de
continuer à travailler de la maison il
s'agit d'une des laboratoires japonais
de Hory afin de créer une société plus
accessible
[Musique]
ces vidéos sont viral le robot et une
des vedettes de l'Arena de basketball
olympique
livre le ballon du match rugby et
d'autres semblable à lui ai bien
récupéré les 10 kg le stade d'athlétisme
Jeux Olympiques de Tokyo espère être une
vitrine exceptionnel pour l'innovation
est la vision futuriste nippone
partenariat avec le
transport de matériel
dans les aéroports pourrait s'en servir
l'accessibilité universelle c'est la
vision du comité organisateur des jeux
de Tokyo dans ce café qui partage cette
conception du monde il est déjà possible
d'avoir un aperçu du futur et si
Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada Tokyo